[Music]
and now for morning rounds I look at the
medical news of the week according to
the Centers for Disease Control more
than one-third of American adults are
considered to be obese a new study out
this week from the American Medical
Association's cardiology journal
examined the link between body mass
index and cardiovascular disease it's a
topic that has generated some
controversy due to the theory of what's
called the obesity paradox we are joined
from Los Angeles by CBS News medical
contributor dr. David David a gets doc
good morning what is the obesity paradox
morning Alex so this idea that people
who are overweight or obese actually
live longer than people who were normal
weight and this is that one of the large
studies 190,000 people that debunked
that myth so so doctor what did what did
the studies show about the relationship
between BMI and and cardiovascular
health so handsome e BMI is body mass
index that's you know your weight and
height in terms of a figure and what it
showed is that people who are obese that
is the largest BM is they lived two to
three years shorter and they had
dramatically higher rates of heart
disease people who are just overweight
so not yet obese
those individuals had more heart disease
but live just as long as the people who
are normal weight and the I think
important thing is that when you have
heart disease significant heart disease
your quality of life goes down and so
even if you live the same being
overweight and normal weight the quality
of life was different so there is not so
much of a paradox when it comes to
obesity is that right
no question about it being significantly
overweight increases your risk of cancer
and heart disease and decreases quality
of life and now we can say that numbers
two to three years from this study of
over 190,000 people all right so you
heard it here it's been solved our next
topic deals with the ongoing research
into the relationship between diet and
cancer
a new study this week in the Journal of
Clinical Oncology looked at the role of
nuts in the colon cancer survival it was
an observational study involving 826
patients all with stage 3 colon cancer
they recorded what they ate after being
treated with surgery and chemotherapy
they were followed for an average of six
and a half years the study looked at the
association of nut consumption with
cancer recurrence and death and David
did consuming nuts actually make a
difference in this study it did and I
previously been shown that people who
were again overweight people with higher
insulin levels and people rates lots of
sugar products actually had shorter
survivor with colon cancer in this study
nuts predominantly tree nuts actually
can lower insulin we know it can affect
diabetes and gave larger survival with
colon cancer it's really important to
note this isn't a randomized study they
didn't say half the people you eat nuts
you don't they did questionnaires and
two servings a weeks of nuts had this
significant benefit okay you mentioned
tree nuts can you give us some specifics
on exactly what kind of nuts those are
dammit I thought you were gonna ask that
so it's almonds its hazelnuts this
chestnuts its avoiding the peanuts the
ground nuts and the nuts from the trees
have the benefit and it seems to be
those oils actually lower insulin people
say well I don't want to eat nuts
because it has fats but those turn out
to be good fats so David are we gonna
expect more research about the
relationship between diet and cancer
well listen if this study shows a
survival advantage to eating nuts I hope
so and the hope is we could do real
randomized studies you know in this case
eating nuts isn't that difficult two
servings a week and so you know you may
just do it even though there's not a
randomized study to show this because of
the data that we just talked about but
that being said we want to do real
randomized studies with food going
forward because in many cases it's just
as important as the drugs we give I did
not need another reason to go eat more
cashew nuts but I finally have found
what almonds those are my feels I feel
much better because of this Alan I'm
glad
finally hitching a ride for some finding
ways to and from the doctor's office can
be problematic but just this week the
ride-hailing company uber announced uber
health through an online dashboard
doctor's office staff can schedule rides
for patients they can even schedule a
ride up to 30 days in advance
patients don't even need a smartphone or
the app to use it as uber will text them
the information or call on a landline if
the patient doesn't
a cell phone it is all it is also HIPAA
compliant this seems like a very good
thing dr. David agus oh yeah you know
three million doctor's visits it's
estimated were missed last year because
of difficulty getting a ride so this
could dramatically and predominately the
elderly increased their health by
allowing them to show up to doctor's
visits and there's a dashboard so the
doctor or the hospital order of the car
and they who watch where the patient is
and as soon as they get there hopefully
the patient will be seen it's really an
impressive way to improve efficiency and
healthcare and you know people don't
have their own rides and get your
Reluctant loved ones to finally see the
doctor right dr. David agus thank you
for rising early to be with us thank you
I appreciate it